Take a moment to think
about your sex life.
Don't worry, I'm a professional,
I ask this question all the time.
My guess is that most of you
are thinking about solo pleasure
or the interaction between you
and someone else, perhaps.
There's probably very few of you
who are thinking about how your sex life
connects to wider dynamics in society.
Let me explain by starting
somewhere a little different.
The gender pay gap has reduced
in the last three decades in the UK,
and we have more women
in senior management positions
than ever before.
But there is also still
such a long way to go.
Britain only ranks 21st
in the world for gender equality.
And not all women benefit equally
from the advances we've made so far.
Today, I'm going to tell you
how the orgasm gap,
which is data about gender
inequality from sex science,
is a lesser known but powerful indicator
of just how far we still have to go.
Progress towards equality in any area
is about breaking free
of entrenched social norms.
And this is especially the case in sex.
In my work, as a clinical psychologist
specializing in helping people
with their sex lives,
I noticed that we're often unaware
of how much of how we are sexually
is dictated by forces outside of ourselves
or outside of our sexual relationships.
What we should say,
how we're supposed to be,
what we're supposed to look like,
who does what and when,
what we're supposed to be into.
These scripts, they're all written for us,
and we learn them from language,
from peers and from the media.
I don't know about you,
but I'm starting to see
a small change in these scripts.
These days,
my social media feeds are full of posts
about women's sexual empowerment
and women's bodily autonomy
compared to, say, five years ago.
And this is great.
But in my work,
I notice that this change
has not yet translated to real life
and to the bedroom.
Not that everyone has sex there,
but you know what I mean.
(Laughter)
I see plenty of women in my clinic
who tell me that they feel
more empowered than ever
to take up space, to call out misogyny,
to demand a seat at the table.
But when it comes to their sex lives,
they can't seem to bring themselves
to feel empowered in the same way.
They tell me that they feel
silenced, disempowered
and made to feel
that they are the problem.
And they don't know how to tackle it.
So why is this happening?
Well, we used to think
that women’s orgasms were hard to come by,
and that because they were "tricky,"
this was the obvious explanation
as to why when cis men
and cis women have sex together,
it's more often the man
who leaves feeling satisfied.
This is a common myth.
And it's kind of got in the way
of us really noticing
and questioning this imbalance
of pleasure across genders.
This "tricky orgasm" myth
has been challenged
by various pieces of sex research
over the last few decades,
and we now know
that when people masturbate,
there is no difference
in the rates of orgasm
or the time taken to orgasm
across genders,
turning this idea of women's orgasms
being more complex or taking longer
on its head.
But this sex science,
and the fact that only a minority of women
can come from vaginal penetration
without any clitoral stimulation,
is still not that widely known,
leaving many women feeling
like they are the problem,
that they're taking too long
or needing something unusual to get there.
When in fact, they're entirely normal.
Feeling abnormal leads them to fake it,
and faking it gives
their partner the wrong idea
of what women's bodies need.
Meaning the next woman
who tries to assert what she wants
or needs with that partner
is seen as difficult
or labeled as “hard work.”
As a result,
research tells us that men
consistently overestimate
how often women orgasm
during partnered sex.
And underestimate how often
women are faking it.
This is the reason why some women
describe partnered sex as like
"listening to your favorite song,
but having the radio switched off
before it gets to the best bit."
(Laughter)
But why does it matter?
Well, the first thing to say
is that orgasms are not the be-all
and end-all of good sex
and we must not treat them as if they are.
Good sex can bring connection,
stress relief, affirmation,
intimacy and fun.
And orgasms are just
another reward like these,
that serve to make us feel good
and keep humans coming back for more.
But what if the pleasure
of one group of people
is consistently privileged
over the pleasure of another?
What does that tell us about our society?
I mentioned earlier
that people of all genders
can orgasm at a similar rate
when they're alone.
And that rate is
about 95 percent of the time.
The orgasm gap refers
to data from sex science,
which tells us how our
chances of orgasming
can move from this 95 percent
when we have sex with another person.
The biggest gap we see
is for women having sex with men.
When their chances of orgasming drop
from this 95 percent
they might expect alone
to around 65 percent
with a regular partner.
We see an even bigger gap emerging
with casual or hookup sex
between women and men,
when women's chance of orgasming
drops further still.
Crucially, men's rate of orgasming
when having sex with women
stays at around 85 to 95 percent,
whether that's a regular partner,
casual sex
and just as reliably
as when they're on their own.
We don't see such a dramatic orgasm gap
when LGBTQ+ people
have sex with each other.
So, for example, women
having sex with women
can expect an orgasm rate
only slightly less
than when they're on their own.
This data is important
because it tells us that it's gender
which is responsible for inequality
in the experience of orgasms.
Not anatomy, not capacity for pleasure,
but rather whose pleasure
is prioritized as most important.
As a society, we still
aren't signed up to an idea
that women's sexual pleasure
is as important as men's.
We're happy to strive for it,
but only if the route to achieving it
doesn't jeopardize men's pleasure
in the process.
Now there is a complex mix of factors
which maintains the orgasm gap.
Firstly, not knowing what's normal.
And feeling as if it's your
body which is wrong.
Falling for this old idea that your
orgasms are somehow tricky,
even though you know
that they're not when you're alone.
Secondly, women being socialized
to put other people's needs first
and being polite so as to not hurt
someone else's feelings or ego.
And lastly,
the simple fact that the patriarchy
shows itself in the way
men and women have sex together.
The sheer physicality of a sexual script
which favors penis and vagina sex
above all else as "real sex,"
simply suits men's anatomy more.
This is one of the reasons we don't see
such a dramatic orgasm gap
when women have sex with other women,
and we can learn from this.
Ditch the script and have more sex
which looks like the sex you enjoy alone.
So, what are we to do?
Stop faking it.
Yes, I know you've all done it.
And you're so, so good at it.
(Laughter)
I know it comes from a place
of not feeling normal
or wanting to communicate something
or trying to protect
someone else's feelings.
But all faking does
is strengthen this patriarchal script
and means your needs
are less likely to be met over time.
We can also notice how inequality
shows up in the bedroom.
Is it OK with you that your needs
are sidelined in favor of someone else’s?
How does that fit with your values
around equality
and other areas of your life?
It’s OK to be motivated by something
other than orgasms when you have sex.
But this should be your choice to make,
not some kind of sexual
glass ceiling based on gender.
And lastly, by showing up for each other.
If more women felt able
to be upfront about their pleasure
and what their body needs,
this would pave the way for women
collectively to benefit.
It would mean the next woman who tries
to be open about what her body needs
would be less likely to be dismissed
as complex or unusual.
It would change the story.
It would redress the balance.
But this journey isn't just
for women to take.
Men can show up here also,
by believing women
when they say what they need.
These women are not the outliers
you think they are.
They are the voice of change.
Men can also show up by understanding
that women's capacity for pleasure
is equal to their own
and by genuinely championing sex
which has mutual pleasure at its core,
even if that means sacrificing their own,
more comfortable position
of privilege from time to time.
So, let's start a revolution.
After all, who knows what the impact
of gender equality behind closed doors
might have on the rest of society.
Thank you.
(Applause and cheers)